Olá, seja muito bem-vindo ao nosso canal.
Hoje vamos falar sobre um tema fascinante,
ao mesmo tempo que é essencial para a sua saúde,
que é a exposição solar.
Tema polêmico.
Talvez você já saiba que o sol é crucial para a produção de vitamina D.
Mas o que você talvez não saiba é que os seus benefícios vão muito além disso.
Vamos explorar como é que a luz solar interage diretamente com o nosso corpo,
ajudando a otimizar a nossa energia celular
e também ajudando a melhorar a nossa saúde como um todo.
Então, fique comigo até o final desse vídeo.
É muito importante para a sua saúde.
Assim você vai entender como transformar o sol no seu maior aliado.
Quando falamos sobre a importância do sol para a vida,
podemos pensar nos exemplos mais óbvios, as plantas.
Elas precisam de luz solar para realizar
a famosa fotossíntese que você aprendeu na escola,
um processo vital para o crescimento e a produção de energia.
Mas você sabia que o nosso corpo também se beneficia diretamente da luz solar?
Isso você não sabia, né?
Isso é utilizado para produzir energia celular.
Imagina só a gente fazendo fotossíntese também.
Assim como as plantas, nós capturamos a energia do sol,
só que de uma maneira totalmente diferente.
Quando os raios solares tocam na nossa pele,
o nosso corpo tem a propriedade, tem a capacidade de absorver
luz vermelha e infravermelha, convertendo essas luzes em elétrons
que alimentam as nossas mitocôndrias.
Parece ficção científica, né?
Então, essas organelas celulares, as nossas usinas de energia,
elas são responsáveis por produzir a nossa moeda energética, o ATP.
É o combustível essencial para o funcionamento do nosso corpo.
Agora, vamos falar sobre algo que poucas pessoas sabem,
a relação entre a saúde celular e o sol.
Imagine isso.
O nosso corpo é composto por trilhões de células
e cada célula depende de energia para funcionar.
Se não criamos ATP suficiente,
os processos menos essenciais do nosso corpo
começam a ser aos poucos desativados.
Então, você se sente mais cansado, sem energia
e ainda pode estar se expondo ao maior risco de doenças crônicas, como câncer,
ou também diabetes e problemas cardiovasculares.
E é por isso que a luz solar é tão crucial.
Ela alimenta diretamente o transporte de elétrons
na cadeia respiratória mitocondrial,
a cascata fosforolativa mitocondrial,
ajudando o nosso corpo a produzir energia de maneira eficiente.
Apesar de todos esses benefícios,
a verdade é que muitas pessoas morrem de medo do sol, evitam o sol.
Estudos mostram que quase 60% da nossa população
passa menos de uma hora ao ar livre por dia.
Então, nós sabemos que os dermatologistas e vários outros médicos
tiveram um papel muito significativo
nessa criação da fobia ao sol, essa heliofobia.
Mulheres e jovens em especial
estão cada vez mais presos a ambientes internos.
Isso é preocupante porque o sol não apenas otimiza a produção de energia,
mas também regula a melatonina, o ritmo circadiano
e melhora a qualidade do sono.
Então, para aproveitar o máximo benefício do sol,
é ideal você se expor à luz solar durante o meio-dia
usando roupas que exponham boa parte da pele.
No entanto, existe um cuidado importante que você precisa ter.
Se você consome óleos vegetais ricos em ácido linoleico,
é o caso da maioria dos óleos de semente que você consome por aí,
óleo de soja, milho, canola, gerassol,
você pode estar mais vulnerável a queimaduras solares.
Esses óleos infelizmente oxidam quando expostos à luz ultravioleta,
causando inflamação e danos ao DNA.
Por isso, é importante eliminar esses óleos da dieta
antes de aumentar sua exposição ao sol.
Troque por óleos mais saudáveis, como é o caso do óleo de coco,
óleo de abacate, a manteiga ghee.
Eu falo muito sobre isso em um vídeo no canal recente, dá uma buscada lá,
que eu falo sobre a polêmica dos óleos vegetais.
Mas, e se você já tenta se expor ao sol e mesmo assim sente que isso te faz mal?
Isso pode estar relacionado a algo chamado estresse redutivo.
Basicamente, o seu corpo pode estar acumulando elétrons em excesso nas mitocôndrias,
o que bloqueia a produção eficiente de energia.
E como é que faz para resolver isso?
Uma estratégia interessante é o grounding, já falei disso aqui no canal.
Nós chamamos aqui no Brasil de aterramento.
Caminhar descalço na terra ou na areia, por exemplo,
vai ajudar a descarregar esses elétrons acumulados.
Outra alternativa é o uso do azul de metileno,
que eu também gosto muito, que vocês veem em alguns vídeos aí,
o frasco que eu tenho com água, com esse azul de metileno diluído.
Esse composto químico tem propriedades incríveis,
que ajuda a desobstruir o transporte de elétrons no corpo.
No entanto, é crucial abordar as causas profundas do estresse redutivo
como uma exposição a poluentes ambientais, excesso de estrogênio,
que é muito comum hoje, que tem muitas substâncias químicas no ambiente,
o xenoestrógeno, que imita esse hormônio,
e dietas ricas em ácido linoleico, que eu já abordei.
Então, concluindo, a luz solar é mais do que apenas um complemento para a sua saúde.
Ela é muito importante, é uma verdadeira fonte de energia e bem-estar.
Desde a otimização do sono até o combate às doenças crônicas,
o sol desempenha um papel essencial na nossa biologia.
Então, a minha sugestão para você é simples.
Reconecte-se com a natureza, aproveite os benefícios da luz solar
e veja como isso pode beneficiar e transformar a sua energia e a sua vida.
E lembre-se, para colher todos esses benefícios,
é muito importante fazer isso com segurança e de forma consciente.
Se você gostou desse vídeo, deixe o seu joinha, deixe o seu like,
inscreva-se e compartilhe com seus amigos, seus familiares,
compartilhe com alguém que também precisa dessas informações.
Um grande abraço, um beijo no seu coração.
Você é fera!
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça o bem.
A vida de alguém pode mudar também.
No canal da Dr. Lola, induz a se envolver.